Quite often when you hear therapists
talking about people going through the
grieving process,
they say that there's a the anger stage,
the denial stage,
the depression stage,
the bargaining stage,
and finally the acceptance stage.
Most people in this country voted to
leave the EU and I think some of the
remainers are still at the anger and
denial stage.
There is a very clear set of ideas as to
what we do next.
The good Lord may not like them,
but I think there are perfectly good
arguments in that document which I'd be
happy to send you to explain or teachers
we can do next.
Douglas,
can I say that this argument about
bereavement is one of the most patched
realizing
statements I have ever [inaudible] about
this 52
you just said we have democracy where
you accept that that is a process.
You accept that that means that when it
goes against you,
you do not start refusing to pay your
taxes.
You do not have a right to violence or
other than unpeaceful demonstrations,
but on the day after a Labor government
is elected,
Tory party activists and and ps decide
the very next day that their main aim in
life is to make sure that at least
within five years that is reversed and
the idea that they should go into
parliament and vote with the Labor
government because that is accepting the
will of the people is absurd.
I completely accept as a given fact,
we are going to leave the European good
of you.
Youtube,
I am complete with that.
We are going to lead well when you say
it's good to you except that supplies
and I wasn't [inaudible] that we
shouldn't accept it.
What leads seem to suggest that we
What I am suggesting is that it occurred
over the next year that there was a turn
of events by which on February the 21st
next year we had a referendum that went
52 to 48% the other way that would be
equally legitimate as the one that went
52 to 48 they say,
can referee.
I look,
oh,
you think there is almost no chance of
that occurring,
but to suggest that it's somehow
illegitimate,
an undemocratic for some people to want
that suggest that he's only really
understand democracy having
okay elected.
They're not because I've been appointed
that voted for the government in power.
Whichever it was.
Did you,
that was your interpretation of
parliament through the ballot box?
My Lord,
not for appointment.
Okay,
let me bring in other people.
Let me bring in other people.
You'll have a chance to come back.